avoid camera movement especially with
the DSLR like a t2 I any camera so it's
it's it's it's whether it's a on a on a
DSLR or red or any camera its camera
movements of privilege it's not a right
it's an indulgence there's why you
shouldn't you should do it always as
little work as you can an idea shouldn't
be any more we had Einstein's sadness
i'm going to screw this up everything
should be as simple as possible but no
more so in other words use a tracking
shot zoom in but only to an effect or a
better example maybe is omit unnecessary
words Strunk and white a sculpture
should be as small as it can be to
communicate the idea that might mean it
needs to be the size of a building in
some cases but could also fit in the
palm of your hand everything else is
just hubris and ego
you